OK la team, écoutez bien. Ce groupe a toujours été une famille.
Mais la donne vient de changer.
Aujourd'hui, Dominic Toretto roule tout seul.
Tu vas tourner le dos à ta famille ?
Je sais que c'est grave, mais le lâchez pas aussi vite.
C'est notre dernière chance...
De rassembler à nouveau notre famille.
Fais pas ça, Dom.
T'es prête ?
Je te garantis une chose...
Personne n'est prêt pour ça.
Elle est l'incarnation même du terrorisme high-tech.
Il y a des milliers de voitures dans cette ville. Et là...
Elles m'obéissent toutes.
Maintenant je sais ce que ressentent les flics qui nous prennent en chasse !
Freine, freine, freine !
Aaaaaaah !
Oh, ça craint !
Londres...
Abu Dhabi...
Cuba...
Nos chemins se sont déjà croisés, Dom.
Sans que tu t'en rendes compte.
Je crois qu'il est temps de te rappeler...
Pourquoi tu as choisi d'être ici.
J'ai pas eu le choix !
Pour attraper Dom, vous aurez besoin d'un petit coup de main.
Tu peux me dire pourquoi tu fais venir ce buveur de thé avec sa tête de crapule élevée au pudding ?
Je crois que ces t-shirts trop moulants, ça empêche le sang d'aller au cerveau.
Tu devrais mettre une taille au-dessus.
Vous deux, vous allez bosser ensemble.
Génial.
Depuis le temps que j'attends ça, on a un tank !
C'est à mon tour !
Bien ou bien ?
Ha ha !
Ils ne lâchent jamais l'affaire !
Tu croyais que ce serait un combat de rue ?
Dis donc, c'est pas une torpille ?
Tiens le volant !
Quoi ?!
T'es cinglé !
Trop stylé sur ce coup là, Hobbs !
Wouh !
Je sais pas pourquoi tu fais ça, mais je sais une chose,
c'est que tu m'aimes.
Feu !
Ça va secouer, les gars !
DOM !